the clark county school district is  honoring more than 18 thousand dedicated  educators with a bunch of activities  this is of course  teacher appreciation week teachers over  at harley harmon elementary got a sweet  treat today from  freed's bakery teacher appreciation week  a chance to honor those who  lend their skills and their passion to  teach the children of southern nevada  our teachers have done an amazing job in  really going from  face to face to distance ed maintaining  student engagement  doing the best i can something that  nobody in in the world  really has been trained to do this and  so proud of the work that our  18 000 teachers have done but also our  adjunct professors our teachers at home  our parents can't thank them enough for  what they're doing for  us you know this past year  absolutely thank you to all the teachers  later this week clark county school  district will celebrate the new  educator of the year and the nevada  state teacher of the year